so grow can you speak to the scale of
this thing what what just for people who
are not familiar uh how big was it
um and any other interesting things you
understand about its operation when it
was active so it was uh when we finally
got looking through the books and you
know the the numbers came out is about
1.2 billion dollars in sales it's kind
of hard with the fluctuation value of
Bitcoin at the time to come up with a
real number so you kind of pick a daily
average you know and go across so what's
the operation was done in Bitcoin it's
all done in Bitcoin you you couldn't you
had escrow accounts on you know you came
in and you put money in an escrow
account and you know it the transaction
wasn't done until the client got the the
drugs or whatever they had bought
um and then the drug dealers had sent it
in there was some talk at the time that
that the cartel was starting to sell on
there
um so that started getting a little
hairy there at the end what was the
understanding of the relationship
between organized crime like the cartels
and this kind of more ad hoc
new age
uh Market that is the Silk Road I mean
it was all just chatter it was just you
know because like I said Jared was the
inside so we saw some of it from for the
admin sides and Ross had a lot of
private conversations with the different
people that he had advised him
um but no one knew each other I mean the
only thing the only thing that they knew
with the admins had to send an ID to
Ross had to send a picture of their
driver's license or passport which I
always found very strange because if you
are an admin on a site that sells fake
IDs why would you send your real ID and
then why would the guy running the site
who profits from selling fake IDs
believed that it was
but fast forward tangent they were all
real IDs all the IDS that we found on
Ross's computer as the admins were the
real people's IDs what do you make of
that because I have other clumsiness
yeah low hanging fruit I guess I guess
that's what it is I mean I mean I would
have bought I mean even Ross bought
fake IDs off the site he had federal
agents knock on his door
um you know and then he got a little
cocky about it the landscape the
Dynamics of trust is fascinating here so
you trusts certain ideas or like who do
you trust in that kind of Market what
was your understanding of the network of
trust
I have nothing anyone trust anybody you
know I mean I think Ross had his
advisors of trust but outside of that I
mean he required people to send their ID
for their trust he you know people stole
from him uh there was there's open cases
of that
um
it's a criminal world you can't trust
anybody
what was his life like you think
lonely
can you imagine being trapped in
something like that where you the your
whole world focus on that and you can't
tell people what you do all day
could he have walked away
like someone else take over the site
just shut down either one just you
putting yourself in his shoes the
loneliness the the anxiety the just the
growing immensity of it so walk away
with some kind of financial stability I
couldn't have made it past two days I'm
not no I don't like loneliness yeah I
mean my my wife's away I probably call
her 10 12 times a day we just talk about
things you know I just you know
something crossed my mind I want to talk
about it and I'm sure she and you like
to talk to her like honestly about
everything so if you were running Silk
Road you would you wouldn't be able to
like uh hopefully I'd have a little
protection I'd only mention to her when
we were in bed
um to have that marital uh connection
but but who knows I mean she's gonna
question why the Ferrari is outside and
things like that yeah
well I'm sure you can come up with
something why didn't he walk away it's
another question why don't criminals
walk away in these situations well I
mean I don't know every Criminal Mind
and some do I mean AV unit walked away I
mean not to go back to that son of a
[ __ ] but there's a theme to this but
you know uh Ross started counting his
dollars I mean he really kept track of
how much money he was making and it
started you know getting exponentially
growth I mean he I mean if he would have
stayed at it he would have probably been
one of the richest people in the world
and do you think he liked the actual
money or the fact of the number growing
I mean have you ever held a Bitcoin yeah
oh you have well he never really held
the Bitcoin can't hold it it's not real
it's not like I can give you a briefcase
of Bitcoin right you know or something
like that like he liked the idea of it
growing he liked the idea I mean I think
it started off as sharing this idea but
then he really did turn to like I am the
captain of the ship and that's what goes
and he was making a lot of money and
again
my interactions with Ross was about
maybe five or six hours over uh over a
two day period
um I knew DPR because I read his words
and all that I didn't really know Ross
um there was a journal found on his
computer and so it sort of kind of gave
me a little insight
um so I don't like to do a playbook for
criminals but I'll tell you right now
don't write things down
um there was a big fad about people like
remember kids going around shooting
people with paintballs and filming it I
don't know why you would do that why
would you videotape yourself committing
crime and then publish it like if
there's one thing I've taught my
children don't record yourself doing bad
things it never goes but goes well so
you actually give advice in the other
end of logs being very useful for the
defense perspective uh for
you know if information is useful for
being able to figure out what the
attacks were all about Vlogs are the
only reason I found Hector monstergar I
mean the the one time his uh VPN dropped
during a fox act and I he says he did he
wasn't even hacking he just was sent a
link and he clicked on it and then 10
million lines of uh of logs there was
one IP address that stuck out